Guerry sick author of the book October
Surprise in the introduction you say
that a book such as this can only serve
as a cautionary tale why'd you write
that because that's exactly the way I
feel about it that you can't go back and
refight the election of 1980 you can't
charge bill Casey he's bid you can't
really do much of anything about it
except to warn people that this sort of
thing goes on and that they should watch
out for it
and I think that that's the important
part of the book it obviously has
political significance and other things
but fundamentally it's to warn people
that if the democratic process is going
to work you have to be careful in the
event that somebody's been hiding under
a rock over the last couple months this
book is about what this book is about
the attempt by the Reagan Bush campaign
to meet with the Iranians and delay the
release of the American hostages until
after the election and have them
delivered to Ronald Reagan instead of
Jimmy Carter to try to affect the
outcome of the election in 1980 why did
you write it it's an easy question and
it's a long answer I didn't know I was
going to write this book
even three years ago when I started
doing the research I I sent out to write
a book about the Reagan administration's
involvement with Iran and I thought that
I was going to deal primarily with the
iran-contra affair as time went along I
started working on the book and I
decided that to to really talk about the
iran-contra affair and to talk about the
Reagan dealings with Iran you had to
look at what happened in 1980 that was
where it all began and as I started
doing the research on this and I thought
that would be rather quick and easy I
found that that was a story in itself
and it just got bigger and bigger until
finally I had to make a decision do I go
ahead and write the book I intended to
write or do I write something else I
finally decided I had to go ahead and
write this other book so this is a this
is a
steak this was never intended to happen
I noticed in the you know the
introduction to closed that you signed
this off of September of 1990 this is
only a couple months later how did this
book come out so fast it really is
pretty amazing
I wrote a an article an op-ed article
for the Washington for the New York
Times in April April 15th 1991 and it
attracted a good deal of attention and
Random House came to me in May and said
they would like to do the book and so in
mid-may we sat down and had a discussion
about what I could do unfortunately I
had not written the book before I wrote
the article I should have of course a
terrible mistake and I so they said okay
how quickly can you write this book and
I took a very deep breath and I said
August and they said alright we'll lay
down a schedule and we will go ahead and
plan for production and everything else
to get the book out in January and so I
started writing furiously I disappeared
from sight from May 15th until literally
the end of August and finally I surfaced
again with the full manuscript I gave it
to the people at Random House times
books they gave me two superb editors
who took the book and spent about two
weeks tearing it apart and putting it
back together again and we had
negotiations over that and when I signed
off on that in September that was when
we had put the final touches on that
manuscript but even after that we went
ahead making changes and fixes into
October and then they put it straight
into the press it came out and literally
from was out then on November 11th
actually the first books came off the
press I actually held one in my hand on
November 6th which you know was really
only a month after we had stopped making
final changes to the thing so it's an
extraordinary piece of work and they
clearly decided to go quickly because
the
story keeps moving and they didn't want
a lot of the story to get away before
the book came out as it turned out the
timing was really remarkable did you
actually write it yourself I certainly
did
every word what do you do for a living
right
where's home I live in Manhattan have an
apartment I have been I was gainfully
employed up until about three or four
years ago when my kids graduated from
college and I decided that since I've
been spending most of my money on their
very expensive educational habits
I was now free to either start
accumulating some of that money or to do
without it and I decided to do without
it I will go to work for myself
researching writing and doing what I
wanted to do I never made a better
decision in my life I have a little tiny
study about the size of this table in my
home I go in I have my computer there
the world's shortest commute from the
bedroom to my little study and that's
where I work I've got a modem I've got a
telephone I've got a fax machine I've
got everything I need I can communicate
with the rest of the world and I sit I
research I write and I have a very good
time and do you work for any other
institution yeah I'm an adjunct
professor of Middle East politics of
Columbia and that this semester means
I'm teaching a class once a week is this
a political book in other words did but
maybe I can ask it better did this book
come out because you want to affect the
process or did it come out because you
wanna make money well I never have any
objection to making money that's
perfectly acceptable and I think any
author that says they don't want to make
money on their book has got to be crazy
but I wrote it you know I was in the
White House when this happened when the
election of 1980 took place and I had a
chance to witness these things firsthand
I wrote another book called all fall
down about the Iranian Revolution in the
hostage crisis and the way I the way it
looked from my vantage point and when I
started going through this again what I
had to do in this book was actually to
go back and
reexamine a whole body of history that I
thought I had known and it was like
tearing the pea off an onion you kept
pulling it back and saying wait a minute
I thought I knew what happened at that
time and then deciding discovering that
in fact you'd only known part of the
story so it was a discovery process it
was a mystery story I'm an analyst by
vocation I spent 24 years in the Navy as
a intelligence analyst naval
intelligence and I ended up as a Navy
captain and spent a lot of my life in
fact all of my life for all practical
purposes amidst in one way or another
putting together complex puzzles this is
perhaps the most complex puzzle I'd ever
run into and so there was a real
challenge at doing this and then finally
as I got into the material and began and
came to a you know to have a serious
grasp of this mass of stuff I think I
felt a certain obligation if people
carry out this kind of nefarious
political activity they get away with it
and they win elections and nobody ever
calls them on it what that means who the
democratic system is we're gonna have
more of that they're going to do it
again and the word in Washington among
the insiders who know these things will
be this works try it you'll like it so I
felt that the least I could do was to
put the thing out in public and say here
it is here's the evidence that's
persuaded me see if it'll persuade you
and if so at least holding that up as a
warning signal to other people to say
wait a minute maybe you can't get away
with the next time as you know I've got
them right here there have been a couple
of publications that have worked this
whole theory over pretty good
one of them is a cover story and the
November 18th New Republic camera is
kind of far away we'll get up closer so
you can see what this cover looks like
people probably seen this to understand
the question is what October Surprise
and inside
this is written by Steve Emerson and
Jesse Furman
let me just read one paragraph almost
every primary source cited by sick or
frontline has been indicted or was the
subject of a federal investigation prior
to claiming to be a participant in the
October Surprise finally evidence we
have uncovered shows that William Casey
and George Bush could not have been
present at the meetings alleged by the
sources first of all remember that Steve
Emerson wrote that piece although it
says November 18th on the cover in the
peculiar world of magazine publishing in
fact it was published a full week before
my book came out on the 11th so it was
in I read it a week before and Emerson
interviewed me for this and I said look
my my book is going to deal with these
issues in some detail and the use of
sources that you're alleging in this
article simply aren't true he chose not
to use my information and not to wait
for the book so this was written before
the book came out and does not in any
way reflect what I've done in the book
because he didn't know what I was doing
in the book other than what I just told
him in the interview as a result the
article is kind of odd in a sense
because what it does is it creates a
sort of hypothetical conspiracy theorist
who believes in this story and says here
is this mythical individual and if they
believe in this they must believe in the
Tooth Fairy because there's this and
there's that in it and it sets up a
whole array of straw men and then knocks
them down but as I told Steve in our
interview before he published this many
of the sources the first five or six
pages of this article are devoted to one
source Richard brenneke I don't use him
at all and in fact with all due modesty
I believe that I debunked Richard
Rennick II more effectively than Steve
Emerson does so this debunking effort I
think
you know slightly misguided and off the
mark but the charge in there about the
sources indicate that Casey could not
possibly have been in Madrid are just
are just simply false they in Emerson
had talked to a guy in London who said
that Casey was at a conference we had
known the case he was at a conference in
London and he was there for about a day
and a half and he know the records are a
little fuzzy but let's call it a day and
a half that he was in London he was
missing for four to five days he had
left the states and on the on Friday or
Saturday night came back on Wednesday
are you talking about so in case the
audience had Oh
October 1980 this is this is this is
July of 1980 July of nineteen minutes
right and the allegation that I make is
that the source that I talked to who was
that eyewitness who was there at the
meetings said that Casey was in Madrid
during this period of time and we had
actually traced Casey's movements
outside the country and nobody had ever
admitted the case he was outside the
country in Madrid meeting with that he
was in the de Madrid meeting with an
Iranian representative Mac Tico ruby who
at the time was an associate of Khomeini
is today he is the Speaker of the
modulus the Parliament in Iran doing
what making a deal that this was where
in fact the deal began that resulted in
the delay of the hostages and the
release of the hostages to the Reagan
administration so my source had talked
about this and we traced Casey out of
the country and they say well he was in
London he was in London there's
absolutely no doubt about he was in
London for a day and a half all day
Monday and half of Tuesday he left on
Friday or Saturday he didn't get back in
till Wednesday there was plenty of time
Madrid is thirty minutes
I mean it's 90 minutes from from London
by plane and was used routinely as a
shuttle point to go back and forth to
Madrid for these people that were
operating on this operation so I just
don't agree with the article at all and
I
wish that the article that and the
Newsweek article had waited until after
the book came out so that they could
have in fact dealt with what I said
not with this mythical individual who
supposedly is believer in a conspiracy
theory I don't identify with the
individual that they create
I didn't seize the cover now of making
of a myth the October Surprise which is
also a debunking of your book exactly in
fact the two articles came out the same
day and are really quite similar ok you
know a lot of people are accusing you
all kinds of things in writing this book
let's go back to these articles and I
want to ask you what's the motive of the
New Republic which is owned by Marty
parrots and what's the in your opinion
the motive of Newsweek which is owned by
The Washington Post company I don't
think it's my business to examine their
motives they are examining mine
they say I'm a dupe that I've been taken
to the cleaners by these people that
they think that I'm being used for
political purposes and so forth I'm not
going to all I can say is that the
articles came out together quite some
more one week and as far as I know they
didn't work on these things together
well I take that back in fact the
Newsweek article refers to the two
Emerson's article and so forth so they
were in contact with each other before
this time and they use exactly the same
pieces of evidence they've talked to the
same people and they go about it in very
much the same way presumably their
motive is that they didn't believe the
story I you know I find it difficult to
believe in it the more that really
bothers me about both of these stories
is that if you look at the end of the
Newsweek story it ends up saying that
maybe this whole thing began with a big
misunderstanding and what if the people
that were talking in London to the
American representative the the Carter
representative thought they were really
talking to the Republicans and this was
all just a case of mistaken identity
I mean this is just wildly speculative I
was in the government at the time I know
about the meeting that went on with the
American representative it definitely
there was no case of mistaken identity
and I told them that also but they
seemed to like this theory and they ran
with it and I honestly don't understand
what was going on here let me ask you
this and maybe you don't want to deal
with Marty parrots is an avowed Zionist
he believes very strong in the State of
Israel he's said it on this network any
suspicion that one of the reasons they
would pick this line is because one of
the things you accuse Israel of doing is
being an intermediary and in the weapons
well it's a legitimate question and
again I can't examine their motives it
is true that this book is not very
flattering to Israel and that I would
anticipate that that people who feel
strongly that way would feel a need but
as I say the articles in both cases are
not really directed at the book as much
as they are at the the general story
these came out before they either one
neither one of them claimed that they
actually have read this book or are
responding to what it says they're
simply saying in advance what what they
think is going to happen it may in fact
be more of a reaction in some respects
to the Sai Hirsch book that had come out
just a few weeks earlier which uses one
of these sayings one of the same sources
that I do Arab in minashi who is a
former Israeli intelligence operative
and who plays a prominent role in my
book as well as inside Hirsch's book and
he is saying things that the Israelis
are very very unhappy about so the fact
that that well for instance that that
Steve Emerson got access to personnel
records from the Intelligence Division
in Iran in Israel that personnel records
have very been minashi which nobody else
had been able to lay their hands on
suggests that he had at least the
Israelis were prepared to cooperate with
him on this when he interviewed me he
was in Israel that's where he was doing
his research and that's where he called
me to do the
the interview did you sense by the way
when Steve Emerson called you that he
was gonna come out against what oh yes
oh yes it was very clear know him I'd
known him we had we had talked various
times in the past I was aware of various
stories that he had done in research
that then we had not known each other
well instead passing how about and this
may be really stretching things but
Newsweek some by The Washington Post
company and you first wrote your article
in The New York Times on April the 15th
this year where you laid all this out is
there any sense that there's a
competitive thing here The Washington
Post and again I have no reason to
believe that the Washington Post
inspired them to do this no I really
don't think that was that was the issue
The Washington Post however has been
quite hostile to the story and from the
very beginning as has not been very
receptive to the idea and again I can't
explain the penalties of that either
but my impression is that that John
Barry the chief reporter who did this
once he got the information about Casey
in London he quit looking and quit
thinking that there was anything else to
look for that had that disproved
everything and John Berry's British he
has British that's correct
so his connection was in Britain for the
information that he he's he's British
but he works in United States now but it
was his information was his source
British his source was British as a
matter of fact yes and mr. Chadwick at
the Royal Army Medical College the Royal
War Museum was the person who provided
the information about Casey being in
London and you know we had known about
Casey being in London before we I in my
book there's a photograph of Casey in
London I mean and I died that was put
out before these articles were written
so the fact that Casey was in London
certainly didn't come as a surprise to
me it was in the book it was described
and there's a picture of Casey you know
at the
during this conference that he was
holding in London so that didn't come as
a as a surprise to me at all but there's
a sense that once that information was
found
once that was located that that John
Barry's simply decided that everything
about this story was false and I think
they just didn't look hard enough
because that in my view does not mean
that this could not have taken place
that there is a and you know I must say
maybe I shouldn't say this but in order
to understand this story
you've got to read it maybe that's not
fair in other words to understand the
anchors I tried to figure out how am I
gonna ask you questions about well
probably it really is true you know that
and that in one sense it's why I wrote
it because dealing with this subject
among the people that work with it
there's a kind of shorthand you know
Hashemi says this and you know what
that's talking about it you know the
first Madrid meeting this happened and
so and you go on and on for the other
for a normal reader or for a normal even
well-informed individual it's impossible
to know what this shorthand is talking
about and you need some kind of a god
this book among other things is an
attempt to create a guide that will
easily take a reader through this very
complex story and I hope show why what
the motives would be of the individuals
involved what the evidence is does it
now exists something about the sources
who they are where they come from what
their background is why they would or
would not have access to certain
information and that is a no so I hope
that the book will at least lift the
level of discourse so that anybody who
wants to talk about this subject in the
future at least will have a sort of set
of guide path guideposts set out for
them that you can then know at least
what the baseline of information is and
can go on from there let me talk about
the journalism of this whole thing with
you if we can it seems like some
different people chosen up sides on this
yes that's really true how about the
network's I noticed on page 236 you say
three other journalists were
particularly generous and helpful then
you mentioned Terra Sun and shine those
of ABC TV's Nightline took an early
interest in the story introduced me to
some key sources and with her superb
team of researchers broke several parts
of the story did they then have an
interest in it once they got to working
with you Tara had started working on
this story before I ever met her and had
done a lot of independent research one
of the interesting things about working
on this story was that I was working on
my own I don't I don't have a research
staff I don't even have a secretary it's
just me and I go do my thing and a lot
of the other reporters and other people
who had become interested in this story
over time for one reason or another
mostly because they thought there was
really something there and it had been
overlooked and covered up and that it
needed a lot more digging those
reporters were often working on their
own time they had very little
institutional support they had no
bureaus to draw on they had no research
support for the most part but they were
interested and we didn't have the luxury
of fighting among ourselves in terms of
you know I go first and I'm gonna get
this scoop but basically everybody that
was involved in the story was interested
in the story and was interested in
getting it out and was interested in
finding out what really happened and it
was a rare an unusual set of
circumstances but it was a pleasure an
absolute joy to work on the story from
that point of view that you didn't have
to feel that somebody was just milking
you and they were going to run off and
and publish behind your back or they
were going to be telling stories about
you or something else it was a good
group a smart group and a lot of and and
and we did pursue this thing sharing
information among ourselves helping each
other out
sharing sources if I suddenly found that
that there was a lead out on the West
Coast someplace that I couldn't pursue
there was a guy that I worked with out
on the west coast that I would call and
say hey if you have a chance could you
talk to so-and-so
and that he would do that and call me
back and send me a transcript of the
interview or say there's nothing there
and so forth we shared among ourselves
so Tara was one of the people who I
shared in from
and others are named in the book as well
does that mean she has a stake in it I
mean that sideline has a stake in it I
don't think so
it meant that Nightline was ahead of the
game they had more information faster
than any of the other networks and you
know if there is a professional jealousy
there I think that maybe one of the
sources of it we ever on the ABC payroll
for this I've not been on any payroll of
any organization for this except for the
20th century fund which provided me a
grant to do this book now I have not
worked as a consultant for ABC ever
who's the 20th century fund 20th century
fund is a nonprofit organization in in
New York which has been around for many
years and what they specialize in is
giving grants to into for single author
books on policy issues and they've been
doing it for years I think political no
they're not are they partisan no they
cover the waterfront you think that
they're we're interested in your book
because they knew that the slant it
would take they the proposal that I
wrote for them was not for this book it
was for a much more general book that
was really examining the relationship
between the Reagan administration and
Iran so they didn't they couldn't have
known what they were going to get and
what I did was about the fall of 1989
maybe 90 I went back to them and I said
look I gave you a proposal I promised to
write you a certain kind of a book and I
had a chapter outline and everything I
said I'm not gonna write that book right
now I said you don't owe me a thing and
I said if you want me to I'm going to
just put that aside for the moment and
I'll come back and write that book for
you later I owe it to you and I'm
forgetting to do that the book that I'm
going to write is going to be very
controversial very messy and is likely
to get certainly me in trouble but it
could get you in trouble too and you're
you're quite free to just drop out at
this point tell me to go off and do my
own thing and then when I come back we
can do this other book together
they thought seriously about that and
said go ahead and write it and gave me
full support to continue pursuing the
subject and they don't necessarily
endorse it I mean in the sense of saying
that this is their thesis but they
thought that it was an important policy
issue and it needed to be looked at and
that's after all what they were there
for and Richard Lyon the president of
the foundation is I just think a
terrific guy and I had great support
from them all the way through they
didn't have to do this and it's a risky
thing for them as well for any nonprofit
institution but they took it where did
they get their money
it's an endowment it was given to them I
wish I knew the name of their founder
they all shoot me for not being able to
say that publicly but some years ago a
gentleman very wealthy gave the money
for this very purpose and the
institution has been going on for I
don't know how many years are you aware
of any other projects that they've
involved in that the audience might be
familiar with gee I wish I had done a
little more homework I mean I I am aware
I mean they've got they put out I think
you know eight books or more a year I
shouldn't be talking just off the cuff
like this because I really haven't done
the research but they they put out a
it's a considerable range of books that
they publish every year what they do is
they take an author on just as if they
were giving him in advance and say we
give you so much time you write a book
for us and when they get the book they
own it they take the book and then they
go to the publishers and say just as if
they this is if they were an agent
almost and try to place the book if they
can't place the book then they become a
publisher and they publish the book
themselves but they publish a wide range
of things on European policy on Social
Security on health care on foreign
policy most of its domestic policy
though most of their books focus on
domestic policy rather than on foreign
policy but there are a number of foreign
policy books is this the only book
you've done for them yes your front-line
connection there's a Bob Perry I believe
Bob Perry and wrote
raus see the same Bob Perry that used to
be with Newsweek that's correct
who's done our show many times here the
reason I bring that up it's interesting
had he still been with Newsweek he might
have been involved in this they said
there that's right story Bob Perry has
been interested in the story for a long
long time
and he's been working on it on his own
he couldn't get support that means week
in fact to work on this story
and that's now he's been working on it
on his own freelancing and then he
proposed as I understand that he
proposed this idea of a special to PBS
and hooked up with Robert Ross who is a
television producer who also speaks
Persian it turns out
which is very convenient in this
particular thing and who lived in Iran
for a while and they set to work the two
of them to go out and and do a
television version of what I was doing
basically in print
let me this may sound like it's not all
that important but it it just seems to
be a thread through all this going back
to the Newsweek piece I found it
interesting that John Murray's piece led
off by saying the outlet was hardly
prestigious this is for the first part
of this whole story the executive
Intelligence Review which is a LaRouche
publication did you read that I read the
article you know the article but then it
says the next I mean this is when this I
read the news we Carter's Newsweek
article then they points out that when
the story got his next boost in April of
87 it was in the Miami Herald and then
it moves from there is that nobody paid
much attention to it then and then it
moved the herald story didn't get much
played but when bani-sadr next spoke to
Flora Lewis of the New York Times in
August of 87 the story grew the only
reason I mentioned this is that you had
access to the op-ed page of the New York
Times on April the 15th of this year and
then the front line story Iran what the
next day that's correct
how does all this work man and and why
is there any of this but no but and why
is it all of a sudden in order to get
the attention I had to get to the New
York Times first what is this what's the
well you know it's a it's an interesting
point because inevitably in a
complicated or highly controversial
political issue but the time the story
breaks in a big way and comes to a lot
of people's attention it has already
been covered by the alternative media
that's not at all unusual that
alternative presses smaller in these
papers are covering these stories doing
the real investigative reporting and
very frequently the the big newspapers
are busy reporting sort of what is
happening sort of recording history
whereas the littler presses are hungry
they're enthusiastic and they're
energetic and they're out there digging
like crazy and they're coming up with
stuff some of it bad and some of it very
good and usually you'll find that the
origin of the story for instance the
inslaw story would not we probably
better not get into that a whole a whole
nother can of worms but any big story
that you look at often there was a
subterranean press that that covered it
first and some reporters that were out
there digging who often in the end don't
get full credit for what they do this is
simply another example that people were
out there digging around and the
mainstream press are very slow to pick
up on these things I've found the
mainstream press to be really quite
timid in dealing with a tough political
issue one that really goes to the bone
that isn't just sort of cosmetic a
little scandal somebody misusing funds
somebody's sleeping with somebody else
that has you know in the political arena
but really goes to the heart of the
thing maybe that's what it means to be
mainstream is that you're extremely
conservative about making accusations or
carrying things on so how did I get to
the
what was your question how did I get to
the the opioid page of the New York
Times or why didn't they buy your people
why did they buy my piece well the way
it happened was that in the spring of
1990 a an editor at the op-ed page of
the New York Times called me up and said
I've been hearing about this October
Surprise theory and she said she thought
there was quite a story there and if it
was real it was one of the biggest
stories of the decade all time and she
thought it really ought to be looked at
and wonder what I was doing I said I am
working on it she knew that I was
working on it
she said well would you write something
for us on the thing I said no no I'm
definitely not ready yet that I've done
a lot of research but I'm nowhere near
ready to write the story there's just so
much that I don't know and I'm missing
she said well let's stay in touch
and I said she said do you have anybody
else to suggest and I suggested two or
three other people that I said they
could contact that might be willing to
write a story for him she called me back
and said well let's stay in touch on
this thing now there's no immediate rush
on the thing so we did for a year and we
would talk every month or two and she
would say you know how are you doing I'd
say well am I making some progress are
you ready to write and I'd say no and
that was that finally in the spring of
from January 1991 on the tempo of this
really picked up very dramatically we
had a bunch of new sources new things
were coming together Bob Perry and
Robert Ross had been out scouring
territory they had new interview
material I had interviewed John sheet
hashing me and he'd given me a whole new
dimension of this story carrying it on
to Madrid in the meetings with Karoubi
and there was a sense of momentum and
even excitement about of the way the
story was was developing suddenly after
all this time of grubbing around with
little tiny details suddenly there was a
modest breakthrough
and so they said their documentary was
getting put together and they were
getting ready to go on the air with it
and we agreed very clearly that it
probably would be very useful to have
something in print to go along with the
television show so I figured you know at
some point I'm gonna have to write about
this and this seems to be the moment to
do it because we now had all of this
together so I called my friend at the
op-ed page and I said I'm ready are you
ready and she said let's see what you've
got
so I wrote him a piece but I thought was
three times too long but I said it's
hard to compress this story into a few
sentences and I said take a look at it
and see if you think you can edit it
down to make something out of it they
thought about it for several days called
me back and said we're prepared to go
with it but we needed to be a little
longer got it have answers to this and
that and then we went into an intensive
editing phase word by word phrase by
phrase that went on for I've forgotten
most seemed like a good part of a week
they knew that front line was coming out
on Tuesday and the New York Times not
wanting to be scooped said we'll make
room for it on Monday and much to my
amazement gave me almost the entire
op-ed page for this article it was
amazing and in frontline care I mean
they like the idea you're gonna hit the
New York Times first I think we had
mixed emotions on one hand I think they
were happy to have a mainstream
publication coming out with the same
story at the same time they were and it
went real credibility and real punch to
to the story it got people's attention
and I think a lot of people looked at
the frontline story that would not have
I mentioned it in my in the op-ed page
so I mean so the op-ed piece mentions
the fact that frontline is going to be
doing this
next day on the other hand like all
journalists I think there were those who
thought it would be great if we were out
there first and that's but I I can't
speak for frontline and I thought they
were basically pretty happy with the
result they got they got tremendous
numbers on that show in terms of
listeners tuning in on the last page
where you sign off and in your book you
make this statement
Barbara Honaker deserve a special
mention why well as I said in the when
to read on from there that I didn't
agree with Barbara on many many issues
we didn't work together at all she was
not part of this little group that
worked together but Barbara Honaker
wrote a book also called October
Surprise not only how could he do that
there's absolutely you can have 15 books
by the same name the same year if you
want to this you can't copyright a book
title and in fact there often are two or
three books by the same title that was
that was an editorial decision on the
ground that this phrase has come to
simply represent this story and the
trying to come up with a more elegant
title in effect people would know what
they were talking about and this at
least somebody looks at that cover they
know what the book is about it's not
it's truth in advertising if there's
nothing else but any case she had
written the book that came out in 1989
called October Surprise I disagreed with
many of the things in that book but she
had been absolutely dogged in her
pursuit of this story and she had
uncovered a number of sources and
uncovered an amount of information and
kept the story alive at a time when
absolutely nobody believed in it at all
so I thought that at a minimum
she deserved credit for the work that
she has done for which in many cases she
is not guiding got much appreciation
even from me so this was I'm not sure
it's fair to ask you this but why is it
that the executive
tell us the review of LaRouche that
publication was just kind of cast aside
Barbara honaker's book was even made fun
of by people and then all of a sudden
Gary SiC is bought by the New York Times
and frontline and your book is out there
well maybe it's not a fair question to
ask me because you need to ask somebody
else why they did that let's face it I'm
a fairly mainstream person I was a
retired Navy captain 24 years of Navy
intelligence work I was in the Defense
Department for a number of years I was
in the White House for six years I
worked for three different presidents in
the White House I got out I worked for a
very conservative organization I mean I
worked for the the for the Ford
Foundation doing program work for them I
had done work on the Middle East and I
you know and so forth
it's a it's a very sort of conservative
mainstream kind of it's not necessarily
a routine kind of CV but it it is at
least one that people can look at and
say well gee this this guy at least is
not a crazy coming out of left field and
I did have I had written for The New
York Times before I'd written I don't
know three or four different op-ed
pieces for them at various times in the
past I'd also written for the Washington
Post and I had done commentary on
national television at the time of the
Gulf War and you know I had done a lot
of work so my name was known to a lot of
people and I think that people who would
have said that's ludicrous
that story is unbelievable I will have
nothing to do with it if they said you
know if he's buying this maybe just
maybe it deserves another look just to
see and I think there was a sort of
mixture there in the end who knows what
what the outcome of this will be but
initially it seems to me that was the
that was what and that's what motivated
people to to give me if you like a
second reading getting back to the the
premise of the book on page 146 you say
none of the principles involved have
ever spoken publicly about what happened
and there will never be a full account
of the discussions until that happens
and on the same page you say that in
this meeting there were six Australis
sixteen Iranians in 12 Americans why
haven't any of those people spoken up
well and have I said I said principles
because some of the people there have in
fact spoken up but very few of them very
very few I have tried very hard to talk
to specific individuals who had reason
either to know what was going on or to
have been there in my view this was a
covert political action covert actions
are done in secrecy people are pledged
to keep their mouth shut and for the
most part they do people take those
pledges very seriously partly because
they take a sort of secrecy oath but
beyond that they know that they're going
to be implicated in the thing so they
have every reason in the world to keep
their mouth shut unless as some of the
people who have served the sources for
this they really have nothing left to
lose they've been indicted they're in
trouble they feel that they've been
deserted by the people that they worked
with or they were in very marginal
characters who really had no part in the
major part of the thing and so you get a
little piece of the puzzle so it's not
surprising that the sources that show up
for this are not Boy Scouts and Sunday
School teachers I mean that's not the
kind of people that they use for the
thing and those are not the kind of
people that are now ready to go public
the principles I think have not talked
and how my feeling is the only way
you're ever going to get the principles
to talk and even that is not going to be
easy is with some kind of congressional
investigation that has subpoena power
and that
that is the necessary element to get
beyond this that doesn't mean that you
solve all of your problems immediately
but it does mean at least you're in a
position to begin dealing with them
where did you grow up Kansas I was born
in Russell Kansas the same hometown as
Bob Dole and Arlen Specter as a matter
of fact
Arlen grew up there I went to high
school we the same class
no neither one of them we didn't know
each other in Russell none of the three
of us did but I think it's kind of
interesting this little town of 6,000
people right out on the bear plains of
Kansas it's a lovely spot and I my
mother the book is dedicated to my
mother and I and I make a point of
getting out to Kansas as often as I can
and I always enjoy going back but it's a
tiny little town and I went to the
University of Kansas and when and
basically a by whole life there and only
later on did I leave I the Navy provided
my mobility I guess to to leave Kansas
and would you study I was a French major
in college French literature as a matter
of fact I my specialty was 19th century
French poetry and 19th and early 20th
century most of which I've now forgotten
though not the French I after college I
got a fellowship and went to France for
a year lived with the French family
again studied literature but mostly
studied France I traveled around for a
year and then went into the Navy and
went to the Middle East a lot of time in
the Persian Gulf North Africa in the
Mediterranean what was your first year
in the Navy my first year in the Navy
was in the flagship in the Persian Gulf
what year nineteen
58 and did you get interested in the
Middle East before did you ask for that
ask for that well what I asked for I was
interested in intelligence work because
I it appealed to me because this sort of
putting puzzles together was something
that I really enjoyed doing and I
thought I would enjoy the work and that
was the only place that there was an
intelligence job available when when I
was assigned to there to the flagship in
the Persian Gulf I didn't know where the
Persian Gulf was I had to get out a map
and and find out where it was and I had
a great geography lesson in a year of
sailing around the Indian Ocean and
Persian Gulf places that were
wonderfully exotic and colorful and I in
a sense for a small-town boy from from
Kansas it was sort of join the Navy and
see the world and I've seen an awful
part of the world where did you go after
that first year from the Persian Gulf
I went curiously enough for period in
Paris with some language training and
then went down to Morocco and was
working in the there was a naval
installation a Navy Basin in Morocco
that put out a monthly magazine on
political events in the Middle East and
so I spent it was like up like a year of
being a reporter on a magazine and I
learned a lot about the Middle East and
of course that year read a lot and wrote
a lot and I enjoyed writing it's a great
joy to be able to turn out articles
every two weeks or something like that
and what are you coming on to be a full
lieutenant
pretty soon at that point I was I guess
I was I made lieutenant I guess while I
was while I was in Morocco where from
there well then I would add had a
wonderful I got married while I was in
Morocco and my wife had been at Kansas
University with me and we
got married and then traveled through
France for a wonderful month and then
came back to the states and I had a
series of assignments in in Washington I
went to the Naval Intelligence School in
here in Washington and then later went
out to Fort Meade Maryland and was
watching Soviet missiles and naval
activities from that vantage point and
then went off to Cairo is the assistant
naval attache I was in Cairo from 65 to
67 was there at the beginning of the
arab-israeli war the six-day war I
watched it from the other end the
receiving end and stand on the roof of
the embassy in Cairo and watch the
Israeli planes coming in to hit the
desert sites yeah literally within sight
flying around on the edge the outskirts
of the city
shrapnel falling on your head from
overseer from above as they were firing
off flak guns trying to knock down these
airplanes and made uh I was in one of
the people that was involved in setting
up the evacuation of Americans from from
Egypt drove down to Cairo and tried to
organize an evacuation and very exciting
period of time I loved Egypt I still do
and have been back a few times since
that time my daughter was born in Egypt
how many kids to have a son and a
daughter after Cairo what in the Navy
Cairo I came back yeah we were evacuated
from there spent a short time in Greece
and ended up in Italy with the Sixth
Fleet and again was stationed in Naples
loved Italy and my daughter loved it so
much that she's gone back and she now
lives in Italy and become an Italian
actually she's her Italian is just
perfect we left there came back I went
to the Naval War College and then after
that I got a master's degree in
international relations while I was at
the War College and then went to
Colombia that the Navy has this
wonderful program that a few people a
year are funded to get PhDs
and I was lucky enough to be one of
those and went to Colombia for three
years did all the coursework in the
dissertation finished my PhD came down
to Washington I wrote my my dissertation
on in an ocean great power politics in
the Indian Ocean and that got me a job
in the office of the Secretary of
Defense working on the Persian Gulf and
Indian Ocean issues what year is this
now that was in 1973 - 76 and the
Secretary of Defense is well now James
Schlesinger was James Schlesinger camión
Hall I was there that was basically
Schlesinger's time that's the guy I
worked for most there were over other
people before but it was really
Schlesinger that was the I wrote some
stuff for him and was involved with with
him
but he had commander at this point in
the Navy yep I was a commander at that
time yeah that's right and then went
from there because of my work in that
you know the Secretary of Defense's
circle a system of the vs. security
affairs I got to know a number of people
in the White House in the National
Security Council and when President Ford
was facing election as often happens
people jump ship they get out while
their Robo DXM is still hot and go to
work for a consulting firm or something
and then after the election people flood
back in again and they're always a lot
of holes in over there in the White
House staff during that last year or so
six months to a year and so I was
invited to come over the NSC staff I
thought that's a pretty bad offer I'll
go over there work for six months it
kicked out when the new people come in
whichever way the election goes and then
I'll be out of a job and I'll have to go
scrambling but I did it anyway I thought
I thought it would be a great place to
watch an election from and it turned out
to be a great place to watch the
election from the Carter people came in
after the election I thought I would be
sent back over to the Department of
Defense and they said stay on he a
captain yet I was not but I was
in before the end of the Carter
Administration I was promoted to captain
and that's the rank you left the Navy
what's the rank Arthur maybe you're on
the NSC staff how many people are on the
staff at that point about so I recalled
around 50 professionals it's pretty
small you write in the conclusion
although I was a Democrat I had served
nearly half of my career under
Republican presidents why did you feel
the need to put that in the book because
I know that I'm going to be accused of
political partisanship people are gonna
say this is a political hatchet job
you're just going after George Bush you
want to embarrass him it's a political
season etc and there's no way I can
avoid that I mean I know that that
charge is going to go with it the way I
actually got into this book was not a
carefully plotted event but it does come
at a political time it is going to be
seen as a political document and so I at
least want to make my position clear I
mean that this is where I am and I have
always been a Democrat and though I've
never worked in political campaigns I've
never been a an activist and I think
most people these until this book came
out probably regarded me is generally
nonpartisan I've never really
participated in partisan political
activities this book is likely to be
used in a partisan way it's not written
in a partisan way but it's likely to be
used in a partisan way and there's
really nothing I can do about that did
you find many Democrats in the Navy and
in the officer corps we didn't talk
politics
I seriously no we really didn't talk
politics very much and I honestly
couldn't answer your question I mean I I
I know that some people were Democrats
and some people were Republicans but to
say did you meet a lot of them I simply
didn't identify people that I work with
as Republicans or Democrats you say in
the book and I know that I can find the
there's a line here and you know what
I'm talking about where you say that you
oh he said I would not be human if I did
not confess that I have at one time or
another awakened in the middle of the
with the thought what if all these
people are lying to me is it possible
that all these accounts are themselves a
conspiracy of lies
why did you put that because it's true
you can't work on a story this big
that's complicated in this dangerous
dangerous to your own professional
career and to your own reputation
without asking yourself that question
and I must say that I've answered that
question to my own satisfaction that I
when I finally decided that I was going
to write this book and in the course of
writing the book I believe that the
degree of the number of coincidences
that occur in this story that if you are
going to show that this was a conspiracy
of Lies you have to invent another
massive conspiracy theory to say that
all of these people have been secretly
exchanging information among themselves
that they've got some motive which is
not easy to determine why they would all
be going to this immense effort to put
out this story it's not clear that any
of them are benefiting from it in fact
many of them have been really seriously
hurt by the story and the fact that it
came out personally vilified you know
they've lost jobs in many cases lost
money and in some cases have been
threatened with court cases I mean
Richard brenneke was subjected to a
perjury trial and it's not clear that
they had much to gain from doing this
but you have to come up with a theory
what do they all have to gain how was it
all fit together how were these people
planted Jamshid Hacha me Francis my the
source that I used probably as much as
anyone in the book he didn't come to me
and volunteer his story it took me a
year and a half of dealing with him
before he would finally begin to tell me
his story he had to really trust me
first and decide that you know that I
could be trusted to deal with this and
you know how did somebody plant him
there and have him you know go on for a
year and a half without telling me the
story if this was all part of a plot
to deceive me it's you know it's pretty
damn well done I'll say that if the plot
was done and finally I get to the point
where the coincidences are so
extraordinary that to explain them away
the conspiracy theory has to be bigger
than the real conspiracy and finally you
get to a point and you say I believe it
the author of the book is Gary sick the
title is October Surprise thank you for
joining us it's a great pleasure